[Music]  on the baseline by Covington seven  issues  Wayne wants to take brilliant [ __ ]  lunches lead to Miami he just tell you I  love good games hard all the way down  [Music]  backdoor James throws it down perfect  bounce pass for Kevin Love and it's back  up to 20 there's room now to manipulate  inside the mid lane  every time they jump from the outside  the GEEP who's gonna get the shot here  gets it in Middleton for the time  three seconds left Cleveland triggers it  James  [Applause]  not in a hurry  jover Mitchell into a  [Applause]  and when you get done you've gotta come  in oh my goodness thank you David  [Applause]  I'm James Harden going  brain dumplings with 67 points with 645  remaining tatum drives down that throws  it down  [Applause]  do not foul anybody here on the trouble  it's going to be Tina here that saves  under three second Rijo throws up the  floater  [Applause]